[Music]
the single most important change in
ionic four is the way navigation works
if you're migrating from version three
then you're probably familiar with ionic
snap controller and the ion nap
component but they've been deprecated in
favor of the angular router which is far
more powerful in today's video you'll
learn everything you need to know to be
successful with the angular router in
ionic 4 and I'll show you a few advanced
techniques that you can start putting to
use right away if you're new here like
and subscribe and you can find the
source code at angular firebase com so
prior to ionic 4 the framework used its
own built in nav controller and
component to handle the navigation
between pages in a push pop style way
that you would see on a mobile
application I'd like to point out that
the nav controller will still
technically work in ionic 4 so you might
see some tutorials out there on the web
that use it but it's not the preferred
way to handle navigation and will likely
not be possible in the future I'm going
to go ahead and assume that you know
nothing about the angular router so
we'll start with the absolute basics and
then build up to some pretty advanced
concepts towards the end and also make
sure to watch my angular routing basics
video which is very relevant to the
topic at hand here
and before we do anything I want to give
you a pro tip and that is to install the
augury plugin for angular you can find
it on the chrome store and it will help
you a ton by visualizing your actual
router tree so you can see here that
everything kind of starts from the app
component then we have a couple of lazy
loaded pages and so on
this is a pretty basic set up here but
it becomes very valuable as your
complexity grows I've gone ahead and
generated a brand new ionic 4 app that's
using the tabs template and when we open
this application up the first place
we'll go is into the app directory and
then open the app routing module the
only thing you'll ever really change in
this file is the routes array which is
an array of objects where you define the
actual routes in your application there
are three basic types of routes that you
can define your typical vanilla route
would just be one that loads a component
then an ionic we have lazy loaded routes
which are automatically generated with
the ionic CLI as we'll see here in a
minute then you might also set up a
redirect to take one path and point it
to some other path if we look inside the
routing module here you'll notice that
it has the load children property that
points to a different module in this app
that's an example of lazy loading which
is a really important concept with ionic
when you generate a page with the ionic
CLI it will be lazy loaded by default
and what that means is it's using a
feature from web pack called code
splitting and the reason we lazy load
things all comes down to performance for
progressive web apps this pattern allows
us to split our code into smaller chunks
which will give us faster initial page
load speeds on the web so let's look at
something a little more practical let's
go ahead and generate a new page and
then we'll do some routing to and from
that page so I'll say ionic generate
page and I'll call this the animals page
then you'll notice it sets up a new path
in that routes array then it adds the
load children property to point to the
module that has that lazy loaded code so
that's going to render the animals page
component when the animals path gets
activated but where does that page
actually get displayed whenever a
certain route is activated it will
render the page within a specific outlet
by default you have this ion router
outlet inside the app component so when
we navigate to different pages or
components it will render that code
specifically where this outlet lives
this ion router outlet is specifically
for ionic but it's just like the regular
angular router with some additional
internal things going on to handle the
transition animations between pages now
let's take a look at how we might
navigate from our home page to the newly
created animals page and it's actually
really simple all we have to do is set
up a button and give it an H ref
attribute and then have it point to
whatever path we defined if you're
familiar with the angular router you
probably know that href don't really
work and you need to use the router link
directive and ionic it works a little
bit different if you're defining the
link on an actual ionic component it
will intercept that link and use the
angular router as it should
appropriately and as far as I can tell
you can still use router link on non
ionic components without any drawbacks
as you can see in our demo here if we
click on the animals link it will
navigate to that page with the nice
back-and-forth animation but a lot of
times in your app you won't just be able
to navigate with a basic link like this
you'll need to do it in a more
dramatic kind of way to demonstrate this
I'll create another ionic button but
instead of using an href link I'll go
ahead and use a click event and handle
it with a method inside of the component
type script this will actually behave
exactly like this H ref link but we'll
be handling everything from directly
inside our component which gives us a
lot more control to do things
programmatically angular exposes the
router to us as a service which means we
can inject it in the constructor and use
it in any one of our components there's
a number of different things you can do
with the router but for now we'll just
use it to navigate from one URL to
another once we have it injected it's as
easy as calling this dot router navigate
and then it expects an array where each
item in that array is a URL segment in
this case we just want to navigate to
the animals path so we passed that in as
the first item in the array then if we
go into the demo you can see it
navigates and looks exactly like our
previous link did but the important
takeaway here is that you can access the
router to navigate by whatever kind of
code and logic that you want to write
and just another little side note here
instead of navigate you can call
navigate by URL and pass in a URL string
directly if that's easier for you so now
that we know how to move from one path
to the next let's go ahead and see how
we can use dynamic data in our routes a
common use case here is when you have a
database full of items and each of those
items has an ID you might start by
showing a list then the user navigates
to a route that has a specific item ID
in it and then you pull that ID from the
database and show its data in the UI so
we already have an animal's page let's
go ahead and generate another component
that's specifically for showing a
specific animal ID assuming that we have
that data in a database somewhere one
pro tip here is to nest your components
inside of a lazy loaded page and it will
automatically add the route as a child
route of that component and keep it lazy
loaded so it's performant within the app
so if we go into our animals module you
can see that it now has this profile
component in there and we can create our
own child routes for it so the route
path is just blank which would be
animals because that was declared in the
app routing module then if we want to
route to a dynamic ID we'll set up
another path here where the path is : ID
and then it renders the profile
component so it'll be the profile
components responsibility to check the
idea and then pull the data from the
database so now let's go ahead and route
to this component just like we would
with a regular a tranq the path will be
animals slash whatever ID happens to be
there in this case I'll just pass in
some random ID if we're out to this ID
in the UI you can see that it renders
the profile component and any URL that's
in front of animals will render it but
it's still not very dynamic because
we're not doing anything dynamic with
the ID to be able to extract the ID from
the URL we're going to use a service in
angular called activated route so we'll
jump into our profile component and then
in the constructor will inject activated
route we can get our parameters as a
plain string or an observable if we care
about future changes to it for this
example we'll just go ahead and get it
as a snapshot which means we'll read it
once when the components initially
rendered and we don't really care what
happens to that value in the future so
we'll say this route snapshot dot pram
map get ID and just so we can visually
verify this I'll set up the ID as a
property on the component and then we'll
display that in the UI and watch it
update dynamically if we go back to our
demo now you can see that every time we
navigate to a different URL we get a
different ID displayed in the UI so in
other words we're extracting data from
the URL and using it in our actual
application code the next big topic I
want to talk about is quite a bit more
complex but a lot of people have asked
me how the new tabs template in ionic 4
works even though the nav controller is
deprecated ionic still supports a push
pop style of navigation but it does so
using a thing called named outlets with
the angular router earlier in the video
we looked at the ionic router outlet but
what I haven't mentioned yet is that you
can use multiple outlets within the same
app basically you can create secondary
outlets that have a specific name and
then render content within that
secondary view based on a route change
so in this case here we have a path and
an outlet and if we look in the HTML we
can see that we have multiple router
outlets on this page each one with its
own name proper
the reason we have our routing set up
this way for the taps page is so that we
can show the actual tap bar at the
bottom of the view whenever a route has
changed the big thing to keep in mind is
that if you want to show the tab bar at
the bottom you want to route to one of
the secondary outlets and not the route
outlet the route outlet will take up the
entire viewport while one of the
secondary outlets will still show the
tabs at the bottom the final thing I
want to talk about in this video are
angular router guards guards are a
special type of service and angular that
implement a method that can be
understood by the router in most cases
you'll implement the can activate method
which returns a boolean that determines
whether or not a route can be activated
I'd say the most common use case is when
you have user authentication and you
want to lock down certain routes based
on the user's authentication state when
we generate a guard from the command
line it will generate a file that looks
like this and everything here is
basically it is boilerplate except that
we want to implement this can activate
method and have it return a boolean or
something that resolves to a Boyan like
a promise or an observable a common
pattern I see is to inject the angular
router inside of a guard then we can
redirect the user if they're trying to
access a route that they shouldn't be
activating to demonstrate how this works
I'm going to set up a boolean variable
here called logged in and it will just
have a 50/50 chance of being true or
false if the users not logged in then
we'll want to redirect them back to the
route URL or maybe you want to redirect
them to a signup page and then we'll
return the boolean value from this
method if it's true then the route will
be activated but if it's false then it
will be blocked and the component will
never get rendered the great thing about
guards is that we can write them once
and then apply them to as many routes as
we need they provide really good code
reusability for example we can go into
our app routing module and if we want to
protect our animals route we can add the
can activate property and then add the
auth guard to it and you can even add
multiple guards to a single route if you
watch closely here I'm console logging
the authentication state from our guard
and the console and you'll notice that
when it's false
nothing will happen with the route
but when it's true it will actually
navigate to the requested route in about
a week will expand on all these routing
concepts with my new ionic 4 firebase
course where we'll build out a variety
of different real world features that
use these routing concepts if this video
helped you like and subscribe and if you
want to get access to that course for
free consider upgrading to a pro
membership at angular firebase com not
only will you get access to the upcoming
course but you'll also get access to a
whole bunch of exclusive content
designed to help you build and ship your
app faster thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you soon